So I want you to imagine the absolute most frustrating paperwork heavy interaction you have ever had with a government agency.
Oh yeah. We all have one.
Right. You know the exact scenario. You're sitting in this dreary waiting room. You have this massive stack of incredibly dense forms and you are trying to figure out if you need like form 104 B or 104 C.
And you're just waiting. It always feels like it's deliberately designed to make you just, you know, give up and go home.
Exactly. It's miserable. But now I want you to imagine that you don't have to do any of that ever again. You just have an AI assistant on your phone.
That sounds amazing, honestly.
I know, right? You just tell it what you need and it does all the tedious reading. It drafts these complex legal arguments, fills out the forms, waits on hold, and just, boom, hits submit.
For a normal citizen, yeah, that sounds like an absolute dream come true.
But so here is the flip side. And this is what we are exploring today in this deep dive. What actually happens to the civil servants on the receiving end when suddenly, I mean, a million people can do exactly that all at the exact same time for basically zero cost?
Well, the short answer is that the system just completely breaks.
Yeah. And the long answer is what we are digging into today. Our mission for this deep dive is to explore this brand new, frankly, groundbreaking 2026 paper by Chris Schmitz, Lewis Hammond and Alan Chan.
Yeah, it's called Characterizing Agentic Flooding of Government Services. It's fascinating.
It really is. And we also have a stack of four older background papers that kind of explain the underlying bureaucratic theory here. But this new 2026 paper is the absolute star of the show.
Definitely. And we should probably set the tone right away. This is not some story about, you know, futuristic sci-fi technology taking over the world. There are
no terminators here.
Exactly. The tech driving this is already in literally everyone's pockets. It's a story about the really mundane, messy reality of civic institutions just colliding with everyday AI.
And the incredibly difficult choices that governments are being forced to make, like right now. So to start at the foundation, the authors use this very specific term, agentic flooding. How are they defining that?
So they define agentic flooding as this massive surge in either the volume or, crucially, the complexity of requests that a government service receives.
Right. So it's not just more emails.
No, no. It's a surge caused by AI agents that substantially strains the service. I mean, it fundamentally breaks a government office's capacity to actually process anything.
And their data set for this is just incredibly rigorous. I mean, they didn't just pull like a few random news anecdotes from Twitter.
Yeah, they started with this massive funnel. I think it was 2,288 candidate services they looked at across 11 different jurisdictions and 13 service domains.
Which is roughly, what, 190 government services per country?
Something like that, yeah. But they filtered that massive list down to just 84 verified cases.
Wow. So fewer than one in 20 candidate cases actually survived their filtering. Why were they so ruthless with the data?
Because they wanted undeniable proof. And, you know, proving that a specific block of text was generated by AI is notoriously difficult.
Oh, because the automated AI detectors are basically garbage, right?
Exactly. They're heavily flawed.
Yeah.
So the author set up these three incredibly strict inclusion criteria. First, there had to be a plausible, specific mechanism for how AI could even be used for that survey.
Okay. That makes sense. What's the second?
Second, there had to be actual documented empirical evidence of a change in demand patterns. And third, and this is the one that knocked out most of the candidates, there had to be external attribution of that change to AI.
Meaning like someone officially on the record had to point the finger and say, AI did this.
Yes. And what's really wild is that in 69% of those 84 cases, it was the government officials themselves asserting that AI was involved.
And the rest were third parties.
Yeah. And the remaining 31%, it was reputable third parties. But because of how strict that third rule is, we really do have to be honest about the limits of this study so we don't oversell it.
Right. It's an exploratory, semi-automated, qualitative study.
Exactly. They aren't making causal claims or claims about exactly how prevalent this is globally. I mean, only 25 of those cases even have actual time series volume data.
So because they require that public attribution, they're almost certainly undercounting the real phenomenon.
Oh, 100 percent undercounting.
It's kind of like it's like we are only counting the meteors that actually leave a massive crater and also happen to have a government official standing right there pointing at the sky, taking a photo.
That's a great way to put it.
We know there are way more out there, you know, burning up or hitting unpopulated areas. We just aren't counting them.
Right. We're only looking at the undeniable craters.
So let's look at those craters. What do they actually look like in the real world?
Well, let's take a global tour of the cases because it's pretty mind blowing. Germany is a prime example of what they call qualitative flooding.
Meaning the submissions aren't just more frequent, they are vastly more complex, right?
Exactly. So in German public comment periods for environmental impact assessments, government agencies are suddenly getting these AI-generated letters that run over 4,000 pages long.
Wait, 4,000 pages? Why doesn't the government just, you know, throw a 4,000-page letter directly in the trash?
Because legally, they can't. When they do an environmental impact assessment, they're legally mandated to review all public comments to ensure they haven't missed a unique, valid legal objection.
Oh, wow. So if a citizen uses AI to generate this massive, dense legal argument citing local statutes and all that.
A human civil servant actually has to read it. If they just skim it and miss a legitimate objection buried on page 3211, the entire infrastructure project could get sued and halted.
That is just paralyzing. The human hours required for one synthetic document is insane.
And it isn't just environmental stuff. The German social courts are blaming AI for a 55% year-on-year rise in their 2025 caseload.
And then in Australia, the volume of Federal Freedom of Information, or FOI, requests surged so much the government actually considered bringing fees back just to stem the tide.
Yeah, because again, they're legally obligated to respond and produce documents, no matter how easy it was for someone to generate the request.
And there are financially motivated cases too, right? Like in the Netherlands.
Right. There are middleman films there that are just mass filing municipal property valuation objections. It's a classic arbitrage play.
Because before AI, filing a formal tax objection took real effort and legal knowledge. The cost to file was high.
But now, these firms use an LLM to automatically ingest property data, draft thousands of highly specific, legally sound objections for thousands of homes, and just flood the municipality.
And they take a cut of any tax savings, they drop the cost of filing to near zero, and the local government is left drowning in paperwork.
Exactly. And in Brazil, we see people using AI to submit bad faith medical certificates for temporary disability benefits.
Right. Shifting the burden of proof entirely to the state's medical reviewers. And didn't Japan have to block submissions by IP address for their strategic energy plan?
Yeah, they were just getting hammered. And in the United States, the paper documents these organized adversarial campaigns using AI for voter challenge and voter roll purge submissions.
And just to be very clear to you listening, we are looking at this strictly from a mechanical perspective, totally neutral on the politics.
Right. We're not validating or condemning the political motives there. It just illustrates the exact same vulnerability.
Right. AI allows any organized group to mass produce localized legal challenges that look entirely legitimate. And the local boards have to manually verify every single one.
Yeah, the mechanics are identical. And this brings up a really important distinction the authors make. They split this into quantitative flooding, which is just more requests, and qualitative flooding, which is those 4,000 page letters.
And what were the numbers on that?
60% of the cases are quantitative, 90% are qualitative, and about 50% involve both.
Okay, but when I was reading the methodology, I noticed something. They call this agentic flooding, but actual autonomous AI agents aren't really doing this, are they?
That is such a crucial point. In 87% of these cases, the mechanism is totally mundane. It's just a person using an LLM, like ChatGPT, to generate legally sophisticated text cheaply.
And then they just manually copy, paste and click submit.
Exactly. Autonomous agent web navigation, where the AI independently solves captios and submits the form, is not evident in the data yet.
Wait, so the systems aren't being overwhelmed by some autonomous digital masterminds hacking mainframes. They're being broken by people basically using a chat bot to write dense letters and hitting send manually.
Yes. And you might wonder, why call it agentic then? It comes down to what is being delegated. The human is clicking, but the intellectual laborer reading the statutes structuring the argument, that agency is delegated to the AI.
Oh, okay. The bottleneck was never the physical act of clicking a mouse. It was the cognitive effort required to write a 20-page legal appeal.
Exactly. AI automated the cognitive effort. And that brings us to the theoretical framework. Why are government systems so vulnerable to this?
Right. Let's bring in that 2024 paper by Holling and Baikgard. They define what they call the administrative burden framework.
Yeah, their review of 119 articles shows that citizens don't just pay taxes, they pay in friction. Hauling a bait guard split this into three costs, learning costs, compliance costs, and psychological costs.
Learning the rules, doing the paperwork, and dealing with the stress of the bureaucracy.
Right, and the new paper by Schmitz specifically maps AI's capabilities onto eliminating those exact three costs. AI learns the rules for you, drafts the documents for you, and shields you from the stress.
It just zeroes out the burden.
Yeah. But crucially, not all services are equally at risk. The authors developed a 13-factor risk matrix to predict vulnerability.
How does that matrix work?
They split risk into likelihood and severity. Likelihood looks at agent capability and the expected payoff of the service compared to the effort it takes. Severity looks at the operational impact and response impact.
And the conclusion they reach is pretty surprising, isn't it?
It is. The highest risk isn't actually to basic digital forms. It's to financially attractive services, where demand was historically suppressed just by the sheer friction of the process.
Like tax administration and court systems.
Exactly.
It's basically like a nightclub that never needed to hire a bouncer because the front door was made of solid lead and was almost impossible to push open. I love that. But now AI is handing everyone a forklift to open the door and the club is realizing they have absolutely no
crowd control inside.
That is exactly what's happening. The door is wide open. The club is flooded. So what does the government actually do?
This is the most crucial part of this deep dive, really, the unresolvable tension here. And we have to bring in Richard Zeckhauser's 2019 economic theory paper, which is honestly a bit uncomfortable.
It is uncomfortable because the burden literature, like Holling and Baingard, treats friction as a harm to be removed. But Zeckhauser argues that ordeals like meaningless waiting in complex forms are actually deliberate screening mechanisms.
Right. Because health and government resources are highly subsidized or free.
Exactly. So to avoid just putting a price tag on them or setting hard quotas, the ordeal rations the scarce resources to those who value the most. Only the desperate will suffer through the paperwork.
That is so bleak, but it makes economic sense. And this connects to a concurrent 2026 theoretical paper by Piedrahita and a huge team of AI researchers.
Yeah, including people like Yoshua Bengio. They predicted this exact system level risk from theory alone. They said AI removes the ordeal without replacing the screen, leading to a congested bureaucracy.
Which is exactly what our main paper proves with data. So what are the two ways governments are responding to this?
Well, response one is suppress demand. They just put the friction back. They add fees, IP blocks, force in-person appointments, or add rate caps. And that
works.
It's fast, it's cheap, and it's already been done in 14 of the 84 cases. But, and this is a massive but, we have to look at a 2025 paper by Sharpe and colleagues on agentic inequality.
Oh, and Hammond is an author on both that paper and our main paper, right?
Yes, he is. And they argue that this response is wildly regressive. AI acts as an autonomous delegate. If governments add fees or complex hurdles to fight the AI, they instantly deter the poorest, least digitally literate citizens
first.
So the fastest fix falls the hardest on the exact people AI was supposed to help.
Exactly. Which brings us to response two, increase capacity. Redesign the systems, integrate digital ID, deploy backend AI to process the flood.
That avoids the inequality trade-off, surely.
It does, but it requires years of lead time and massive budgets. That is entirely useless when a surge of 4,000-page complaints is hitting you today.
Right, you can't build a new digital infrastructure over the weekend. So I have to ask this out loud because it's the core question here. What exactly is a benefit system supposed to do when the cost of applying falls to basically zero?
That's the million dollar question.
You literally can't process them all. But if you make it harder to apply, you punish the people who need it the most.
It's a trap. Because of this trap, the authors predict governments will rely on a concept from 1959 by Charles Lindblom called muddling through.
Muddling through. That sounds very bureaucratic.
It is. It just means slapping friction based band-aids on the problem just to survive the immediate crisis day by day rather than fixing the systemic issue.
Wow. Okay. But if muddling through is the default, what do the authors actually recommend governments do to avoid this trap? They must have some near-term fixes.
They have three. Number one, audit service vulnerability now, using that 13-factor matrix before a surge actually hits.
Proactive makes sense. What's two?
Number two, develop a digital identity strategy. This prevents rate limit circumvention and bad faith spam without relying on fees that hurt the poor.
Okay. And the third?
Number three, establish legal certainty. Governments urgently need to know exactly what legal right they have to ignore or block automated submissions. Right now, the law is completely ambiguous.
Which is terrifying for civil servants. And I think that emphasizes the real takeaway here for you listening. This entire deep dive proves this is a governance and institution story, not a technology story.
Exactly. The capability involved is just basic text generation, which is precisely why it's already happening. The crisis is how human institutions adapt.
So just to recap briefly, AI has lowered the cost of interacting with the government so much that it is literally breaking the invisible friction that kept bureaucracies function.
Yeah. Leaving us with this brutal, genuinely unresolved choice between unequal access and systemic collapse.
It is wild. But I want to leave you with one final kind of eerie thought to ponder on your own. Oh, boy. What is it? Well, if the public continues using AI to flood the government with these complex 4,000-page complaints, the only logical
long-term capacity fix is for the government to deploy its own AI to read and adjudicate them.
Oh, wow. Yeah. So
just imagine this fast-approaching future where civic participation is literally just a citizen's AI arguing with the government's AI in milliseconds, completely cutting human beings out of the democratic loop.
That is, yeah, that is something to think about.
Definitely. Thanks for joining us on this deep dive.